بحيرة سد دهو في اقليم كردستان
العراق الى ظهور اطلال قديمة.
واوكرانيا تتقدم. برأيكم هل هذا
انتصار اوكراني ام حيلة روسية
روسي جديد يستهزئ بعقوبات اوروبا
على روسيا التي تسببت بازمة
ادلة على اتهامات بشأن سعيها
للحصول على طائرات مسيرة من
بضربات جوية دقيقة. وتؤكد ان
خسائر القوات الاوكرانية ما بين
هجوما شرسا ضد عدوه ترامب.
اردوجان يتوعد باللجوء الى دول
رئيسيا للسكك الحديدية وممر
موسكو اللوجستي والذي تستخدمه في
الطاقة العالمية. امر الرئيس
الامريكي بتمديد حالة الطوارئ
بالعاصمة فالف تحية واحترام لكم
على هذه المبادرة. روسيا تنسحب
البرلمان بالرباط ضد التطبيع مع
اسرائيل للدفاع عن شرف المغرب.
وذلك بعد تحرش جنسي بمغربيات
مكتب الاتصال الاسرائيلي
سنجار في محافظة نينوى شمال
العراق. ادى انحصار المياه عن
اجبرت فرنسا على اطفاء اضوائها
ليلا. الشتاء سيكون طويلا. انتاج
مثل روسيا في حال عدم ايفاء
الولايات المتحدة بتعهدها تسليم
منح الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيسي تأشيرة سفر لحضور الدورة
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
يطالبون الرئيس جو بايدن بعدم
تتلاعب به امواج الغضب الدولية
حيث الولايات المتحدة عقوبات
والبالغ اثنين وخمسين مليار
دولار. ليعلن هنا تحالف اقتصادي
البحرية في الحرس الثوري
الايراني العميد علي رضا تنكسيري
السابعة والسبعين للجمعية العامة
للامم المتحدة في نيويورك فهل
طائرات ايرانية مسيرة الى روسيا
وانتاج طائرات ايرانية مسيرة.
في اجزائها الشمالية. وزارة
الدفاع الامريكية تحقق القوات
ومضحك. الاحداث والتطورات.
نيويورك تعلن حالة الطوارئ بسبب
سام يسعون لخنق الصين اقتصاديا.
اتعلمون ان اثاث البيت الابيض
غمرتها المياه قبل عقود. نظم
نشطاء مغاربة احتجاجات امام
انقرة مقاتلات من طراز اف ستة
عشر. قصف الطيران الحربي التركي
هذا وسارعت موسكو لمطالبة واشنطن
ولندن امام مجلس الامن بتقديم
تسعين بالمائة منه قد يكون صنع
في الصين ولا تنسوا ان الرمال
التي تحظر التدخل في الانتخابات
الرئاسية خطوة اعتبرها مراقبون
انتشار شلل الاطفال بعدما عثر
على فيروس منه في عينات مياه
الصرف الصحي. سبحان الله هذا
المرض عادة ما يظهر في الدول
العقوبات عن روسيا في حين يفشل
اجتماع وزراء الطاقة في الاوروبي
الصينية. ولم يكتف بذلك البيت
الابيض يقر بمنع الشركات
النمسا والمانيا. تظاهرات الغلاء
تتسع في اوروبا وتطالب برفع
هنا الخارجية الايرانية ان خطوة
واشنطن بفرض عقوبات عليها ارتكزت
ايران واسلحة من كوريا الشمالية
لاستخدامها ضد اوكرانيا. لتعلق
مقار تابعة لحزب العمال
الكردستاني منطقة بري في مدينة
مصاعب مالية. مع اقتراب الشتاء
وتفاقم ازمة الطاقة العالمية
اشباه الموصلات هو مسألة القومي
لا سيما في مواجهة الطموحات
اللحظة بل انها اقرت بسحب قواتها
من بلدة وايضا من بلدة ايزيوم
باحتجاز سفينة اجنبية في الخليج
بتهمة التهريب. وقال قائد القوات
الاوكرانية تقدما على الجبهة
الجنوبية نحو خرزون. بينما يؤكد
دونيتسك والهدف تطويق القاعدة
العسكرية الروسية في القصف يزداد
على تهم واهية ليصرح هنا احد
قادة الحرس الثوري الايراني
الصفراء في فرنسا يعودون للواجهة
والالاف تهتف ضد الحكومة بشوارع
ان وجود الحرس الثوري المياه
الخليجية ادى الى تأمين الملاحة
شركة لامدادات الغاز في المانيا
انها طلبت مساعدة من الدولة بسبب
جديد يضم ثلاثة بلدا في منطقة
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ. ابناء العم
النامية والفقيرة فهل هذه علامة
اقتراب النهاية اعلنت ثالث اكبر
تصريحها. وعبر تليجرام وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تنشر عدة لقطات
الامريكية من اقامة اية مشاريع
لها في الصين ما دفع الشركات الى
عسكرية؟ هذا ما ستكشفه لنا
الساعات القادمة لان المعارك في
يغير مسار المساعدات العسكرية من
الاسلحة الدفاعية الى ارسال
العيون الضيق. لتعلن اليوم
قرارها للعلن. جو بايدن انتاج
المطالبة بالمزيد من الدعم الذي
خصصته ادارة بايدن لهذه الشركات
حدة باكثر من خمسة اضعاف حسب
تصريح سكان مدينة دونيسك. فيما
الروسية اعلنت انها قامت بعملية
اعادة تمركز قواتها من ايزيوم
الحياد. لنحط مرسى سفينتنا في
الجانب الروسي. نحن لا نعلم ما
باتجاه دونيتسك لتقوية مواقعها
في ذلك المحور. لتضيف وزارة
هناك رد متوقع يختبئ في ادمغة
الروس قد يغير المعادلة
جديدة على شركات ايرانية اتهمتها
بتنسيق رحلات جوية عسكرية لنقل
متطورة ام هو فخ ينصبه بوتين
لسحب اكبر عدد ممكن من القوات
انتوني بلينكن ضرورة الاستمرار
بدعم كييف بالسلاح. هنا الغرب
السادس الى العاشر من سبتمبر
الجاري بلغت اكثر من اربعة الاف
سبب انسحاب القوات الروسية. هل
تعود الى دعم اوكرانيا باسلحة
ارسال قواتها وامداداتها
العسكرية الى شمال شرق اوكرانيا.
الدفاع الروسية ان قواتها تستهدف
للجيش الاوكراني في منطقة خركيف
تكتيكات غامضة للهجوم على القوات
الاوكرانية. وزارة الدفاع
الالكترونية موطنها الوحيد هي
الصين. عقوبات موجعة. ملف ايران
القوات الاوكرانية الان تحاول
السيطرة على طريق سريعا في
في التوصل الى اتفاق تحديد سقف
لسعر الغاز الروسي برأيكم هل
الاوكرانية ليطبق عليهم باسلحته
المرعبة. روسيا تقصف بالثقيل
البحرية وتحقيق استقرار مستدام.
هنا نحو خمسين نائبا امريكيا من
تؤكد ان الجيش الاوكراني حقق
مكاسب واضحة في منطقة خلال
الاوكرانية? واشنطن تخنق الصين.
تستمر امريكا بازعاج اصحاب
اسلحة هجومية لنرى تغيرا واضحا
في المعارك. نعود هنا الى شوكة
يتحكم الامريكان بمصير الرؤساء
وجهات سفرهم انه فعلا امر عجيب
بمنطقة دومبس شرقي اوكرانيا.
المخابرات العسكرية البريطانية.
قتيل وثمانية الاف جريح على
محوري خاركيف ونيكولاف حسب
تحدث زعيم انفصالي موال لروسيا
عن معارك صعبة في دونيتسك خاصة
الروسي يتخذ الخيار الصائب
بالفرار. نعم يا سادة التقدم
المعارك في الميادين تغلي. هنا
شعوب اوروبا تغلي. اصحاب السترات
تقول انها لتعزيز عسكرية جديدة
ذاهبة نحو جبهة خركيف. وبينما
وحداته دخلت بلدة والتي كانت
تسيطر عليها روسيا وتعد مركزا
الاوكرانية اسر الفريق اول
بالجيش الروسي اندريسيتشيفو
لكم بكل حيادية وضعوا الف خط تحت
كلمة حيادية. هذه التطورات تطرح
بوتين الملك تشارلز الثالث
لتوليه عرش المملكة المتحدة. ومن
الساعات الماضية ليأتي هنا جهاز
الامن الاوكراني. ويؤكد ان
الملكة اليزابيث تنتظره لمدة
اربع عشرة دقيقة في عام الفين
جنوده يتحركون حاليا في عدة
جبهات في ان واحد وان الجيش
مواجهة هذه الخسارة الفادحة التي
لا يمكن تعريضها. اطلب منكم ان
الميداني الذي يبدو ان اوكرانيا
تحقق لم تنفه روسيا حتى هذه
اعتذرت للملكة وقلت اسف جلالتك
على نباح الكلب امام الضيوف.
زيلينسكي اعلن ان قواته حررت
الفي كيلومتر من اراضيها مع بدء
كييف فجأة لتعلن انها ستغير مسار
المعارك الاوكرانية باسلحة جديدة
تلاتة وخمسين عاما خلال معاركها
في بلاكليا بمنطقة خركيف وهو اول
تساؤلات عديدة حول نوعية السلاح
الغربي الذي وصل في اخر فترة
الهجوم المضاد في شمال شرقي
البلاد وجنوبها. كما كشف ان
لكييب. اتتذكرون في الفيديو سابق
عندما اعلنا عن ظهور امريكا وسط
الايراني من السفر وفرنسا تطفئ
اضواءها. ونيويورك تعلن حالة
اسير روسي به الرتبة منذ بداية
الحرب. الرئيس الاوكراني
تتسع. وامريكا تفاجئ الصين بهذا
القرار. وواشنطن تمنع الرئيس
الحرب النفسية الى الحروب
العسكرية. تطورات مرعبة سنسردها
وبوتين يعاقب الملكة اليزابيث.
القوات الاوكرانية تلقي القبض
وحديثة. اليكم ما يحدث اليوم.
كانت البداية باعلان القوات
تفسير كمحاولة منه للعب باعصاب
خصومه ليخرج ما بداخله. نعم
الملكة اليزابيث الثانية قائلا
اتمنى لكم الشجاعة والمثابرة في
ام خطة روسية ماكرة؟ الجيش
الروسي يقول كلمته الاخيرة
للاهتمام. اليس كذلك? ليعيدنا
الزمن الى اليوم. هنا بوتين ينعي
تنقلوا عبارات التعاطف الصادق
لكم ولجميع شعب بريطانيا العظمى.
البريطاني السابق اللورد بلانكيت
في تصريحات نقلتها صحيفة ديلي
وثلاثة. لتبدو الملكة هنا في
ارتباك وعدم اتزان بسبب فقدان
فنظرت الى بوتين حينها وقالت
للكلاب غرائز شيقة ومثيرة
يمتاز بوتين بابقاء اعدائه
وخصومه في حالة من الصدمة دون اي
اعصابها. لقد حطم البرستيج
الملكي ليكشف لنا الوزير
ميل البريطانية قائلا كان كلبي
انذاك ينبح بصوت عال جدا. لقد
جنسيا. وتركيا تهدد امريكا
العراق مجددا. سقوط عسكري وشيك.
جميع القوات الروسية سرعة
الانسحاب من المواقع. ما هذا
اوج قوتها.
على جميع القوات الروسية سرعة
الانسحاب من المواقع. اكرر. على
الطوارئ بسبب انتشار هذا الفيروس
الخطير. اسرائيل تتحرش بالمغرب
على صيد روسي ثمين. بينما اوروبا
تختنق ورقعة المظاهرات الاوروبية
الذي يحدث وما سر الانسحابات
العسكرية الروسية هل هي الهزيمة